in this video we will study the
immunoglobulins first we will talk about
the structure of the immunoglobulins and
then we will discuss the type and the
function of the immunoglobulins let's
first talk about the structure of the
immune globulin
or the antibodies antibodies are the
gamma type of globulin and there are
basically five types of antibodies but
each of them contain two heavy chains
and do light chains
let me draw our diagram of the antibody
which will help us to understand the
structure of the antibody so as you can
see the genes in the violet color are
the heavy chains and the chains in the
green color are the light chains the
heavy chains are of five types that is
gamma alpha mu Delta and Epsilon and the
light chains are of two types the Kappa
and the lambda now on the each heavy and
the light chain there are variable
regions and there are constant regions
the variable regions are denoted by the
letter V whereas the constant region are
denoted by letter C so as you can see on
the light chain there are two parts the
distal wavy part is the variable region
of the light chain and the proximal part
is the constant region of light chain
similarly the heavy chain is divided in
four parts the distal 1/4 of it is the
variable region of the heavy chain and
the proximal three parts are the
constant regions numbered as 1 2 & 3
now the constant regions confer specific
properties to the antibody the determine
on which surface will the antibody binds
ample the IgE binds to the mast cells
the variable regions determined to which
type of the antigens will the antibody
react to the two heavy chains are bound
to each other by disulfide bonds and
similarly the heavy chain and the light
chains are attached to each other by
disulfide bonds now let's talk about the
various types of the antibodies so there
are five types of the antibodies or the
immunoglobulins the IgG IgA IgM ije and
IgG these can be remembered by the
simple mnemonic gamed not first talking
about the immunoglobulin G this is the
most abundant type of the antibody
present in the humans and it accounts
for approximately 80% of the total
antibodies in the blood
now the IgG is a single unit antibody
that is it only consists of a y-shaped
monomer a molecular weight of the IgG is
150,000 since there is a small antibody
it can easily cross the blood vessels
and the placenta and the immunoglobulin
G is the antibody which is mainly
responsible for the humoral immunity and
the main mechanism of action of the IgG
is by complement mediated destruction of
the foreign cells while talking about
the IgA this can exist as a single unit
or a dimer when it exists as a dimer it
consists of two antibodies which are
joined together by a Jade chain polymer
and the molecular weight of the IgA is
160,000 and it is mainly present in the
body secretions like saliva tears sweat
etc since it is present in the various
secretions the immunoglobulin a prevents
the various types of antigens from
entering the cells of the human body
it consists of the heavy chain alpha
type and the IgG I forgot to mention
consist of the heavy chain gamma type
I am only mentioning here the heavy
chains present in these antibodies
because the light chains are either of
the Kappa or the Delta type now talking
about the IgM the heavy chain present in
the IgM is of the MU type the IgM is the
largest immunoglobulin in the humans
it consists of five Y shaped units which
are joined together by a jade chain the
IgM is a very large antibody and it
cannot cross the blood stream or the
placenta and the IgM is the first
antibody which is produced in any
foreign antigen invasion of the body and
it is also the most efficient type of
the antibody against antigens the
molecular weight of the IgM is 900,000
I'm talking about the IgE the heavy
chain present in the IgE is of the
epsilon type IgE is also a monomer and
it is present in minut quantities in the
bloodstream and the IgE is mainly raised
in the people who have allergies the
mechanism of action of the IgE is that
it binds to the mast cells and causes
the release of histamine from the mast
cells the molecular weight of the IgE is
190,000 the fine life of the antibody in
the humans is of the ijt type the heavy
chain in the IgG is Delta and the
molecular weight of IgE is 180,000 it or
it is also a monomer that it is consists
of a single unit now it is also present
in the body in low concentration the IgG
has no significant role in the body but
it is present on the surface of the B
cells and it is postulated that the IgG
acts as a b-cell receptor for antigens
so this was a short description
regarding the structure types and
functions of the antibodies or the
immunoglobulins I hope you find this
video informative don't forget to hit
the like button also make sure to
subscribe to our channel for further
upcoming videos thank you so much for
watching this video